thor the norse god of thunder has gone
through many changes during his time in
the marvel cinematic universe including
his personality alongside his learned
wisdom and merit thor has become quite
the jokester here are the god of
thunder's jokes in the mcu ranked worst
to best
the first entry into our rundown of the
god of thunder's jokes in the mcu comes
in his very first appearance 2011's
eponymous solo outing having just been
put in place by his father odin played
by anthony hopkins thor's trying to
convince his compatriots to go with him
to jodenheim he hopes they'll see how
the frost giants managed to break
through asgard's defenses in their
attempt to steal the casket as lady siff
reminds him odin forbade such an action
but thor persists in his manipulation
thor asks my friends have you forgotten
all that we have done together
for fandral and hogan thor points out
that he'd led them into the most
glorious of battles to sway valstag he
reminds him that the delicacies he
thought were so succulent that he felt
he'd died and gone to valhalla and then
to sif he posed a simple question and
who proved wrong all who scuffed the
idea that a young maiden could be one of
the fiercest warriors this realm was
ever known i did
true but i supported you it's a coin
flip as to whether you think he was
trying to steal sif's thunder pun
obviously intended but he did give her
due credit in the end
in thor's second standalone movie the
dark world he's cracking more jokes than
in the first probably as a result of
hanging out with tony stark in 2012's
first avengers film when lady siff is
leading asgard's armies and the warriors
3 in battle on hogan's homeworld of
anaheim and clearly thinks things are
going swimmingly thor shows up on the
scene he quickly takes out some enemy
combatants with his trusty hammer
mjolnir and sif is perturbed at his
arrival she complains and thor responds
with a well-timed joke i've got this
completely under control is that why
everything's on fire
total burn thor
as the battle of anaheim rages on in
thor 2 with the enemy surrounding
asgard's warriors an angry roar stops
the fight in mid action everyone looks
around for the source of such a
ferocious rumble that's when a giant
cronin warrior appears and marches
toward thor mcu fans who have seen thor
ragnarok may think this massive humanoid
warrior made of stone is the same type
of being as korg played by taiko titi
they'd be right in thinking this is a
cronin and thus the same species is
quark however according to the dvd
commentary for thor the dark world this
cronin actually is korg and the version
who appears in ragnarok has been
retconned by waititi who also directed
the film
now thor's a big dude but this version
of korg is massive and the norse god of
thunder is about waist height on the
brute but thor of course isn't phased
except joe surrender
and when thor backs up his joke by
smashing cork to pieces he gets in
another zinger anyone else
when roadie played by don cheadle took
the iron man mark ii armor during iron
man 2 and became war machine he stepped
into the big leagues viewers catch a
conversation in avengers age of ultron
where rhodey is regaling tony stark
maria hill and thor with the story of
his own adventures so i take the tank
fly it right up to the general's palace
drop it at his feet i'm like boom you
looking for this
a confused thor asks if that's the whole
story rhodey says that it is that it's a
war machine story thor laughs and
responds saying oh this is very good
then
it's impressive
quality save thor fortunately for rhodey
the story does indeed kill later on when
he tells it to some non-adventure
partygoers
as thor attempts to smuggle loki out of
asgard in the dark world loki is doing
one of the things he does best annoying
thor loki first takes the form of an
asgardian warrior then takes up his own
likeness again and makes his brother
look like sif then loki takes the form
of one of thor's more recent allies
captain america played by chris evans
and offers to have a rousing discussion
about truth honor and patriotism loki
realizes that nagging thor isn't working
out so he finally just asks thor for a
weapon to make the escape easier thor
locks eyes with loki's and appears to be
rustling around for something for loki
to wield at last
little common sense
as it turns out thor did use his common
sense he handcuffed the trickster
i thought you liked trix
it's no secret loki has done a great
many horrible things he's betrayed
pretty much everyone he knows thor
included he's manipulated everyone he's
ever met thor included he's tried to
kill pretty much everyone with whom he's
come into contact thor included these
shenanigans play out over the course of
the first two thor solo films and the
first avengers movie when we get to
ragnarok it's more of the same whether
on asgard earth or sakhar as thor
valkyrie and bruce banner discuss their
exit strategy and how to get through a
wormhole terrifyingly dubbed the devil's
anus our favorite trickster chimes in
with an offer of assistance causing
batter to pull the other two into a
sidebar banner says that he had just
been talking to loki and he was
perfectly ready to kill any of them
valkyrie agrees mentioning loki had
tried to kill her thor who is the
obvious expert on loki's attempts at
murder concurs noting his adopted
brother has tried to take his life on
quote many many occasions before
describing one in particular he
transformed himself into a snake and he
knows that i love snakes so i went to
pick up the snake to admire it and he
transformed back into himself and he was
like yeah it's me and he stabbed me
it's no secret that loki has a thing for
stabbing people especially in the back
but at least thor got a funny story out
of it dr bruce banner deals with a lot
of doubts and insecurities given the
great beast that lives within him while
he's able to summon the hulk at will
getting the big guy to stand down is an
entirely different matter but by the
time age of ultron rolls around he seems
to have developed a system of
de-escalation with black widow involving
holding hands and a lullaby that doesn't
stop him from being dejected about the
entire situation after they had to call
a code green in their attack on
strucker's compound in the opening
sequence of the film as they're flying
back to avengers hq aboard the quinjet
natasha asks bruce when he's going to
trust her and he responds with the
obvious answer that it's not her that he
doesn't trust so she enlists another
teammate perhaps the wrong one to weigh
in asking thor what he thinks of the
hulk thor responds with good humor as
usual gates of hell are filled with the
screams of his victims
when he sees that neither natasha or
banner is in the mood for his jokes he
quickly walks back his remarks
wounded screams mainly whimpering a
great deal of complaining and tales of
sprained deltoids and
gout
another quality save
in ragnarok thor proves his medal by
surviving an encounter with the grand
master's champion aka the hulk
afterwards thor's living conditions
improve immensely he's no longer living
among the rabble of lower card fighters
like korg as a main eventer he's in the
penthouse level quarters with his
opponents the hulk there's training
equipment befitting a champion including
what every noble warrior needs a hot tub
great for soaking sore muscles it's an
essential tool for a fighter's rest in
recovery we're guessing most athletes
choose to soak in a pair of trunks or
other undergarments when in a group
setting but not our hulk which thor
finds out when pressing him for
information thor asks him how he arrived
on sakhar hulk explains that he came
there when the quinjet he took at the
end of age of ultron crash-landed there
well he offered the one-word response of
gwynjet and then mimed a crash with his
hand but it's all there in the subtext
naturally thor wants to know where the
quinjet is now so he could potentially
use it himself having just demonstrated
his propensity for showing rather than
telling hulk gets out of the tub fully
nude to point out where the crashed
quinjet is giving thor an eyeful as he
walks to the window he's very naked
that's to my brain now
thor's only got a few friends at his
disposal when stranded on his car in
ragnarok and they're not exactly keen on
helping him escape valkyrie can't seem
to stop drinking or using that obedience
disc on him so she's not going to be of
much help korg and meek are willing but
they're locked up with all the other
slaves sorry prisoners with jobs so he
can't expect much out of them he needs
hulk's help and he's going to do his
best to convince the great green brute
to help him out even if it means a bit
of manipulation thor tells hulk this is
what friends do they support each other
even so hulk insists that thor is
banner's friend and not his bandit's
friend i don't even like banner
i mean the numbers in science and stuff
once hulk reverts to bruce banner having
seen natasha's message aboard the
quinjet he just wrecked thor tries a bit
of the same with hulk's human
counterpart though it may be with
perhaps a bit less finesse i just told
you if i turn into the hulk i am never
going to come back again and you don't
care
thor has upset banner and has made him
feel used especially when thor says that
hulk is the fire that he needs to defeat
his sister banner tells thor that he's
not his friend
thor then reverses what he said to hulk
earlier no i don't even like the whole
keys oh like bruh i smash smash i i
prefer you
as end game is coming to a close it ties
up its myriad of loose ends in an
extended finale we see thor entrust the
future of the new asgard colony on earth
to valkyrie before boarding the ship
with the guardians of the galaxy
as guardians of the galaxy back together
again
oh we're too fast
on board thor immediately makes himself
at home and changes the map that
star-lord aka peter quill is looking at
star-lord annoyed changes it back and
decides it's time to lay down the law
with the newbie after a brief back and
forth about who's in charge on the ship
drax suggests they fight for the
leadership role i got some blasters
unless you guys want to use knives oh
yes please use knives quill and thor
both laugh and thor cheerfully explains
that they don't have to fight because
it's clear who's in charge there shall
be no knifing one another everybody
knows who's in charge after a brief
uncertain pause quill asks quote me
right
thor's response says it all
yes
you
of course
of course
of course
about 50 minutes into the avengers the
team sits down for its first unofficial
team meeting on the bridge of the
massive shield helicarrier before tony
stark shows up thor discusses with the
other heroes the film's primary
antagonist loki nick fury has just
gotten done interrogating the god of
mischief and cap asks thor what he
thinks his brother's plan might be and
wonders why loki let them take him into
custody after all cap points out loki
can't exactly lead his army while aboard
the helicarrier batter posits that they
shouldn't focus on loki that guy's brain
is a bag full of cats he could smell
crazy on him
the god of thunder takes a surprising
amount of offense to this he warns
banner to watch his words saying that
while loki might be a villain he is
still a prince of asgard and he's my
brother he killed 80 people in two days
he's adopted
things get tense in the elevator scene
in ragnarok as loki leads thor to the
grandmaster ship loki says he's probably
better off staying on zakar and thor
agrees to his surprise thor says takara
is perfect for his brother that it's
quote savage chaotic lawless thor thinks
loki will do great there loki's taken
aback asking thor if he truly thinks so
little of him and thor replies that he
actually once thought the world of loki
but while there might still be some good
in the cantankerous god of mischief he
concedes that they've been walking
separate paths for a long time after a
pregnant pause loki somberly says it's
probably for the best that they never
see each other again and thor twists the
knife patting him on the back and
reminding him by saying that it's what
he's always wanted
suddenly thor has an idea and brightens
the mood suggesting that they do the
tried and true get help routine loki
declines thor reminds him that it works
every time and loki says that it's
humiliating thor asks if loki has a
better plan which he doesn't so thor
concludes that they should do it while
loki is still insistent that they will
not spoiler alert they do get
help please my brother he's dying get
help help him
afterward thor has clearly enjoyed the
routine while loki complains that he
still hates it
it's humiliating not for me it's not
when it comes to comparing adopted
siblings thor loki their respective
strengths are pretty clear thor is the
clear winner when it comes to physical
might and combat while loki is obviously
the more cerebral of the two demigods it
should be no surprise considering one is
the warrior god of thunder and the other
is the trickster god of mischief as such
it's rare that thor gets one over on the
sneaky loki even so loki underestimates
thor having gotten the better of him for
so long but thor is capable of growth as
he demonstrates while they're heading to
the grand master ship in ragnarok and he
posits that loki has stagnated after
they perform the hilarious get help
sneak attack routine loki slinks off to
a control panel to turn thor in while a
magic double walks alongside his brother
of course thor knew that would happen
too during his big speech in the
elevator before suggesting they do get
help thor planted one of the
grandmaster's obedience discs on loki
while patting him on the back after
triggering the device in the hangar he
explains that loki is becoming
predictable then he makes sure to put
the remote for the obedience disk
somewhere loki can reach it okay not
really
just put this over here for you
the opening scene of ragnarok begins
with thor narrating supposedly to us but
maybe to the skeleton in his cage
i don't know what you're thinking
oh no floor's in a cage how did this
happen
he explains that sometimes you have to
get captured in order to get a candid
response from someone before the bottom
drops out of the cage and the god of
thunder is left dangling by a length of
chain thor wonders aloud how long
they'll be there
but where exactly is he thor's location
as it turns out is the fiery realm of
muspelheim inhabited by fire demons the
chief of whom is thor's captor surter
but even chained up in front of a fire
demon thor manages to sneak in a good
joke
clearly thor's been spending too much
time around tony stark
thor's best joke in the mcu is equip
that's a bit understated but absolutely
hilarious after preventing the end of
the world in ragnarok thor returns to
asgard from musklim having ripped
certain's tiara off after witnessing
someone he's pretty sure is not odin
taking in a live performance of the
tragedy of loki of asgard thor unmasks
loki with the threat of splattering his
brother with mjolnir then he demands to
see his father whom he believes loki has
spirited away to accomplish that a
or scourge uses the bifrost to send them
to earth where loki and thor witness the
demolition of the shady acres care home
in new york city loki swears he left
odin right there to which thor asks if
he means on the sidewalk where they're
standing or where the building is being
demolished unsurprisingly loki doesn't
think he's to blame after another
sarcastic remark from thor loki responds
how was i supposed to know can't see
into the future i'm not a witch no
why'd you dress like one
funny and true with the black on black
suit and shorter length greasy hair loki
indeed looks like he just stepped off
the hogwarts express take your best
guess which house he'd belong to we're
pretty sure it wouldn't be hufflepuff
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you